hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer
and today we are going to be talking
about the five
things you need to do and look at before
really honing down on a coding boot camp
before you sign that offer before
making that commitment here are some
five things you may not have thought of
to look at
to really make sure that you are getting
the most of your experience and at the
end of it all
get a job so the first thing that you
really need to look at
when choosing a coding bootcamp is look
at the
timing of the program look at the timing
of the program like such as the length
but also when you would be set to
graduate
so for me i started my coding boot camp
in june of 2020 and i
graduated in october very early october
of that same year
so it's a four-month program and i
graduated in the fall
so for me that was great because a lot
of companies hire in the fall
however some of my peers who graduated
later on
kind of ran into some difficulties when
it came
to the hiring process because they
graduated in the winter they would have
started let's say july
august and they were set to graduate
december january
and the thing is with that time
period companies aren't really hiring
as much because that's their you know
their year end they're focusing on their
books they're focusing
on closing things down etc so when you
really look at
really the trend of hiring hiring is
lower in those months and so
it took them longer it has taken them
longer
to get jobs and get offers and things
like that
and so me when i was looking
at you know when to start and everything
i really didn't
put this into consideration i was like
you know what like let me just start
this is when
you know the earliest time is let me
sign me up sign up
but if i had known this ahead of time
i that definitely could have impacted my
decision making depending on
when i decided to make that career shift
so just something to think about
so piggybacking off that first tip tip
number two
is to look at the length of the program
coding bootcamps
can run in anywhere between like three
months
to six months to a year mine was four
so kind of between that three to six
month term however if you have certain
goals of okay i want to make sure i get
to this this by this date and this date
really
look at how long it will take you to
complete
your boot camp experience and with that
if it is a longer term like the 12
month one or even maybe 18 months really
look down at the curriculum they'll be
covering and then to
what depth because it's important to
know what you're getting into in terms
of not only the boot camp experience but
also
what is supposed to be taught and make
sure
that you're not learning things that
aren't of interest to you in those
extra you know extra months and
everything because
okay cool is 12 months so you'll get
more knowledge but is it the knowledge
that you
really are looking for is it the you
know will it be the job category you're
looking for or
xyz so really look at the term and what
is
going to be covered within those terms
and if you just go to the coding
bootcamps
site whatever one you're interested in
they typically
do have a course breakdown sometimes
it's not
too in detail but they do have a course
breakdown of what's supposed to be
covered
when and if you can actually talk to one
of their recruiters and things like that
i'm sure they would be more than willing
to give you even more details so
really really keep that in mind so tip
number three
you really want to look at the
repayment plan of your bootcamp so
yeah bootcamp is expensive it it very
much is
and so again i'm talking about more
less obvious tips and things to consider
because of course you would consider you
know the cost
and everything but after you consider
the cost and after you see
how to really you know finance it
will you be taking out a loan where
you'll be doing an income share
agreement will you be paying out of
pocket
things like that look at really what the
repayment plan is specifically if you
are choosing
a loan or an income share
agreement so just to break it down real
quick an income share agreement
also known as like isa that's actually
what i decided
to choose for my bootcamp and really
it's just that when you
get a job when you you know secure a
position
you are going to start paying let's say
like five percent 10
15 of your paycheck to the boot camp
directly
until you pay them back what they let
you conquer like borrow
this is different from a loan because
alone
one that could be a private loan that
you went to your own bank for and things
like that and so they'll have their own
terms you'll need to look at the
interest rate
you'll need to look at at what time do
you need to start paying them back is it
a month after graduation two months or
is it during the
actual bootcamp that you need to also
actually be paying them back and things
like that
so you can go through your bank or i do
know if bootcamp is that
give you a loan directly and it can be
different from an income
share agreement because the rates can be
different sometimes with a loan
depending on your credit
it can be um the rates can be lower so
you want to look at your credit also
when it's
when deciding between an income share
agreement
and a loan but with a loan also
it's not dependent on how much you're
making an income share agreement
is dependent on how much you're making
as an engineer
if i'm making forty thousand dollars
post group boot camp
versus making a hundred thousand dollars
post
boot camp there's different percentages
i would need to pay back to them
each month rather than alone it's 300
every month like where you at like bring
that to us if you don't care if you're
making two thousand bucks a month
twenty thousand bucks we don't care just
give us back the three hundred so there
are some nuances
and things like that so really away from
just the cost of the boot camp really
look at
the repayment plan what they expect of
you when they expect of it
how much what proportion they expect of
it each month each
year things like that really look at
those details
tip number four the next thing you
really want to look at
before committing to a boot camp
is look at their employment rate after
graduation
really look at how many of their
students get a job
after they complete the program not only
that but
in what time period do they get a job
if it's saying you know 80 percent
employed
after a year that's very different from
employed after six weeks look at those
um stats and also
look at like look at the notes is it
employed in specific and actual software
engineering
roles or were they not able to get a job
in software engineering and they ended
up going back to like business or
finance
or like being a driver for like uber or
like things like that like when you say
employed do you
mean as a software engineer
or just disemployed just employed at the
trader joe's
across the street just employed so
really really
look at that fine detail because this is
your life like you are
making a huge sacrifice not only in time
but
so much money and so much effort
based on what these people are telling
you so
really look at that fine print and if
they don't offer fine print again
call up that recruiter call up that
office and be like yo what do you mean
by 80
data like i need to know really the fine
fine print and the details surrounding
this
statement so tip number five kind of
going along with chapter number four
with tip number five if the boot camp
you're looking at
states some type of employment guarantee
really
again look at that fine print so what i
mean by this
mine says something like employment
guaranteed
after three months period so
okay if i go through this boot camp and
you know i do the thing
i will have a job after three months
and there was also another thing that
said and if that's not the case
then you get a 100 refund
so really there's really like no like
risk to you it's
you pay this and get a job or you pay
this and get the refund because you
couldn't get a job
so i'm like hell yeah like like don't
gotta tell me tries like where's the pen
but the thing is though when companies
state
this look at the requirements that need
to be fulfilled
in order for you to qualify for money
back in the event that you don't get a
job
so with my bootcamp yo there was a
laundry list of things that you needed
to complete you needed to do or not do
to make sure that you would
end up getting that refund if
you know you don't get the job their
whole
mindset is if you do every single thing
on this
list then you will get a job and so it
went beyond just like going to classes
and completing the assessments
and you know calling it a day it went
into like
like contact you know linkedin members
you know
x times a week and write blog posts
you know x times you know a month and
all this like things that you wouldn't
think
directly related to the course but
in terms of getting a job they were like
if you do all of this
all of these things then you will get a
job and if you don't
then here's your money back
when you pick well one before you even
pick a boot camp
look at this laundry list of things is
it feasible to do
is it some of it absurd is it things
that you're not comfortable doing like
writing
blog posts or reaching out to people on
linkedin if
you know you're more of an introvert or
things like that look at that laundry
list of things
before signing on to a program
because you're guaranteed a job and two
if you decide that you know what like
i'll do whatever it takes you know and
that was me i'll do whatever it takes to
get a job i don't care if
you know you say i need to jog around
the block two times a week for me to
even to qualify for the refund like i
would
do it but but
print it out print out that entire
statement of
all the things you need to do for you to
qualify for that refund because some of
the things
are actually during your courses not
even
after you've you know graduated but
during your courses you need to make
sure that
you know three weeks in you do x y and z
you make sure that five weeks then you
do x y and z
and if the first time you're looking at
this list is after you've graduated then
boom you're already
don't qualify for the refund because you
didn't do the things you're supposed to
do
during your program so before you even
start the boot camp
print that list out hang it up on the
wall and be making sure
you're crossing things out and
constantly looking at it and
making sure that you are fulfilling all
of those requirements
so there you have it everybody the five
things that you really really really
need to look at before
signing on to a coding bootcamp to
ensure that you get the most
of your experience and you know you get
what you paid for
so hopefully that's you know a job or
even if it's not a job but
you being able to start your own company
and things like that you want to make
sure you're getting what you pay for
so thank you so much and please let me
know what you think in the comments and
please subscribe if you liked the video
so thank you